nous sommes au coeur de la technopole de
saint-denis ici les entreprises
orientent leurs activités sur les
nouvelles technologies ou la recherche
la rue maxime rivière nous conduit tout
droit d'ailleurs à la maison régionale
des sciences et technologies pour
l'instant elle est un peu déserte mais
elle devrait prochainement constitué un
nouvel axe de développement est ce pour
cela qu'elle porte le nom de maxime
rivière
est ce que vous savez qu'ils étaient
maxime d'ailleurs non c'est une bonne
question c'est y pas que des terrines et
leurs propriétaires dans l'industrie
sucrière c'est lui qui a inventé le
procédé de cristallisation du succès pas
d'actes manqués qui l'a fait connaître
la can au monde quoi en fait
le souvenir de maxime rivière est
étroitement associé à l'histoire du
sucre ni aux avirons en octobre 1921 le
jeune maxime est un brillant élève du
lycée leconte-de-lisle son rêve suivre
des études scientifiques dans la
capitale mais en france la deuxième
guerre mondiale fait rage bloqué dans
l'île le jeune homme effectue un stage à
quartier français il rejoint ensuite les
forces françaises libres en angleterre
où il s'engage comme officier de marine
la paix revenue il reprend ses études et
décroche un diplôme d'ingénieur à
supélec
de retour au pays il rentre un quartier
français et épouser la fille de rené
payet son directeur avec michel il aura
dix enfants
à l'usiné il côtoie aussi emile hugot
une passion pour l'industrie sucrière
est né en 1953 il reprend donc la
direction de la sucrerie qu'il
restructure totalement techniciens
pointus il étudie toutes possibilités
d'innovation technologique
cristallisation du sucre en continu
centrales thermiques à bagasse ou encore
amélioration des rendements agricoles
sous son impulsion l'industrie sucrière
prend un coup de jeune
soucieux du développement économique de
son île maxime rivière pour le monde des
voyages à l'origine de la création de la
société de pêche sia de bourbon
plastique ou encore de la sorac au
l'infatigable bâtisseurs du premier
groupe sucrier de la réunion c'est en
avril 1995 à l'âge de 73 ans